liz trust takes charge of a nation not
only in crisis but one in desperate need
of direction offering groceries for as
little as three pounds are being used by
record numbers of people
the new prime minister is promising
communities like basset law in
nottinghamshire that she understands
their struggles
i will deliver on the energy crisis
dealing with people's energy bills but
also dealing with the long-term issues
we have on energy supply
it does use less energy than your oven
so it will end up saving a little bit of
money as this group discussed ways of
cooking using less energy liz trust was
finalizing major plans to impose an
energy price freeze i expected to do
something about the energy obviously
and
the cost of living in general she needs
to listen
to the average person the mum at home
with the children who's trying to
shuffle jobs
get petrol in the car my priority is my
family is my children so to me
helping with electricity
this is it helping with food this is it
um you're not waiting for the prime
minister to come along and save you
you're doing this for yourself i don't
see you at the door
at the local citizens advice bureau
they've never been so busy so joseph how
have you been since we last saw you then
department is stricken joseph is falling
into debt because he can't pay his
energy bills it's just
not right i got 283 pound my last
payment right
and now i've got about four pounds and
three pens left
after the meeting i asked joseph what he
thinks of the new prime minister i mean
i'm so disenchanted by that woman like i
think she's
i think it could be thatcher too it's
like in my opinion right that this is
like being back in the 70s you know like
with the bin man straight and all the
rest
it's all came around again
you don't have faith in her as a prime
minister no
not at all
all eyes are on what liz trust does next
to help ease the pain of the rising cost
of living we've already had some support
packages which were released earlier in
the year and they have helped um
households already but the situation has
changed since then we've had a new price
cap increase and which will take effect
from october and direct debits are
already being put up i think they really
need to provide
much more support than they are
providing at the moment
there are people who really can't pay
their debts they are being tipped over
the edge i never imagined that i would
see this kind of crisis in my life
this area voted conservative for the
first time in 90 years in the last
election but an awful lot has changed
since then and the truth is liz trust
doesn't have long to convince voters
that she's the person to lead the
country in the long term
we will deliver we will deliver and we
will deliver it is a bold promise and
millions of people will hang on every
word nick martin sky news bassett law